oh this was so this made me laugh so
much dude
this made me laugh this is just
incredible hold on oh yeah no uh here we
go here we go this is just so great Tom
Cruise on the red carpet
why can't I do it to where I play it
when I [__] want it I want it to
start playing with sound God damn it
look she says what are you gonna see
Oppenheimer or Barbie first
oh yeah no the way he wrote oh yeah just
already already bullshitting oh yeah not
even a response to are you gonna see
Barbie or Oppenheimer first oh yeah he
says already calibrating [__] if you
had to choose one because there's a bit
of a debate what's great is you're gonna
see both oh dude anytime someone starts
with what's great is your toast dude
you're you go like this oh never mind I
don't you're gonna [__] and I Gotta
Throw that question away
the weekend I think it's like you know I
haven't quite decided it'll probably be
like Oppenheimer first and then Barbie I
think I think it's like you want like
imagine if you see [__] Oppenheimer
first
and then go to Barbie
how [__] terrible Barbie's gonna be
after that you'd be like this is all
pink
Oppenheimer is going to be on on a
Friday do you know what I mean and then
you you can go
um in the afternoon you want that packed
audience and then I want to see Barbie
right afterwards with a packed audience
so
[Laughter]
this was
so funny did I send this to you or did
you say this to me
because you said and then you said so
tired dude he is exhausted at this point
I mean just how much [__] is going
on too because of how he said
I'll probably see Oppenheimer Friday and
you know that means it was Gonna Save
Barbie Saturday but then he didn't want
to be [__] playing favorite so he was
like and then I'm probably gonna go to
see a pack I'll probably go to Barbie
afterwards
so Friday is like you know I used to
plan my days where you start out early
in the morning and you go to movies all
day like also also when did you do this
when you were 12 you have been famous
for 90 years you can't go to the movies
all day dude you'd be [__] you'd
murder somebody you know and I'd go from
one sentiment to the next and I'm gonna
do that no you're not so I'm going to
see them both fact check no you're not
close opening day and also gonna see him
at home
your [__] Tom Cruise dude imagine uh
one take or you know what I'll just get
both tickets now one ticket so I want to
get the ticket for Oppenheimer now and
then I'll also get the ticket for later
for Barbie one please for both both
look at I want to watch it again all the
way through are you gonna watch
no oh yeah
that's great as you can see both on the
weekend I think it's like on the weekend
and wait sorry I know someone's gonna
stop I'm gonna see both on the weekend
and then changes it to both Friday you
know what I'm gonna do I've seen both at
the same time I'm gonna set up two TVs
uh they're gonna be going side to side
and I'll be watching Oppenheimer and
Barbie at the same time and whichever
one ends first uh that's when I kill
myself so
I am quite decided it'll probably be
like Oppenheimer first and then it'd
probably be like Oppenheimer first and
then I'll just never see Barbie
I'm a 60 year old man uh I'm a white man
I'm a six-year-old man I won't be seeing
Barbie
dude I
cannot stand
that these people can't be real uh dude
oh I can see Barbie that's me if I'm Tom
Cruise's level which I will never get
because I I can't [__]
I'd like to see Barbie I'd like to see
Barbie I'm actually Barbie I'm 43. oh
did you didn't know that I'm 43.
I take my [__] out what's this ah
Whoopsie Daisy you made a mistake right
look it got hair all around it I'm a guy
and Barbie I think I think it's like you
want like oppenheimer's gonna be on a on
a Friday I love this do you know what I
mean I love this you can go
I'll probably see it in the afternoon
you want that packed audience and then I
want to see Barbie right afterwards with
a packed audience so Friday is like why
heck
dude it would be it would be
distracting for everyone dude if Tom
Cruise he gets so excited he jumps on
the chair like he did on Oprah
oh my God not gonna see either
I mean that no definitely gonna see open
armor I'm gonna see open armor
so great dude just so funny
[Music]
foreign